less than a year after the U.S Supreme
Court overturned Roe v Wade
the issue of abortion returned to the
high court where justices decided to
temporarily preserve access to a drug
used in most medication abortions
abortion access across the U.S varies
greatly and continues to change what you
have today is you have a situation that
is much more state-specific and I would
say much more volatile here's a look at
how the abortion landscape has changed
since Roe v Wade was overturned
abortion access is currently protected
in 18 states and the District of
Columbia 12 states have near total bans
on abortion in 10 states abortion is
neither banned nor protected the
remaining 10 states have laws that
significantly limit abortion but not all
of them are currently being enforced
some of the most striking changes you've
seen are in republican-led states where
you've seen abortion go away in some
cases almost overnight
in Florida legislators recently passed a
bill Banning abortion after six weeks of
pregnancy with limited exceptions
Governor Ron DeSantis signed the bill
into law April 13th but it isn't poised
to go into effect immediately
Florida was one of the few places in the
South where abortion was still legal it
saw one of the biggest increases in
abortions after the overturning of Roe v
Wade if this goes into effect this will
have a significant effect on abortion
access in the South and around the
country at the same time some
conservative leaning or politically
mixed states have increased abortion
access in Michigan voters approved a
constitutional amendment in shrining
protections for abortion rights
nullifying a pre-row ban Governor
Gretchen Whitmer signed it into law in
early April no one is going to restrict
our reproductive and our Reproductive
Rights and freedom in the state no one
as States hash out their own abortion
regulations a legal battle has caught
national attention and prompted the
Supreme Court to intervene
the battle started in Texas where a
district judge temporarily suspended the
Food and Drug administration's approval
of the drug mifoprestone which is used
in most medication abortions the
decision would severely harm women
across the country
it would deprive patients of a safe and
effective medication to manage their
reproductive Health D's leader another
ruling from the fifth Circuit Court of
Appeals blocked part of that Texas
ruling allowing miffapristone to remain
on the market but with some significant
restrictions including when the pill can
be taken and how it can be prescribed
the bite Administration appealed the
Texas decision and on April 21st the
Supreme Court decided to temporarily
preserve access to mifepristone while
litigation in lower courts plays out
which means the FDA drug makers and
abortion providers have more time before
an official ruling on miffapristone is
made it's actually the first time we've
seen abortion access meaningfully in
Peril even in liberal states even in
places with Democratic Governors and
Democratic legislatures because if the
FDA were forced to pull this drug from
the market that would affect everyone no
matter where you live in the country